how's it going everybody so just like I
mentioned in my last video
Jill Russo took over do a Lowe's
Instagram which is a bar that he owns
part of as he took it over they did a
live Q&A which allowed fans to ask him
some questions my last video talked
about what he said in response to when
are we going to see the trailer for
Avengers 4 and now I'm going to talk
about what he said in regards to the
title also I'm still giving away copies
of Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and ant-man
and the wasp on blu-ray as well as some
special edition posters if you would
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do is to be a subscriber
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so of course the Russo
brothers the kings of trolling Marvel
fans have done it again
so of course during this QA somebody
asked Joe Russo what the title for
Avengers 4 is and of course Joe Russo
knew that this question was coming so
when he was asked what the title was
this is what he had to say
one person
the next one is called Avengers
again king of trolling nobody does it
better my guess is that he had this
planned for a pretty long time now
he knew his QA was gonna be pretty much
all about avengers' fort he definitely
knew he was going to be asked what the
title was I don't actually think he said
the title when this audio cut out
obviously they cut out the audio on
purpose but if you look at his mouth and
try to read his lips it doesn't seem
like he's saying the title some people
say you can actually see him mouth
Avengers annihilation but here's the
thing if the title is Avengers
annihilation like pretty much all of us
think it is right now he's not gonna say
it he knows that we look so deep into
these videos and he's not going to just
give us the title that easily when the
title comes out it's going to be this
huge deal and it's going to be official
from Marvel Studios and we most likely
won't get the title until we see the
trailer this is going to be the biggest
Marvel movie of all time so far and it's
just going to be one of the biggest
movies of all time period there's going
to be a lot of publicity stunts like
this like Mark Ruffalo going on a TV
show and supposedly spoiling the title
there's going to be a lot of stuff like
this happening until we get the official
trailer and title so I don't think he
actually said the title name as the
audio cut out I think we're going to get
the title in a big official way and I
don't think we're going to get the title
until the trailer comes out but I do
think that the Russo brothers are kings
at trolling us Marvel fans but what do
you all think do you think that Joe
Russo actually said the title when the
audio cut out or do you think that once
again he's just trolling us let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you